all right here we are now I want
everybody to know first of all we
started this Monday with some smoked
meat
Brennan brought in basically the side of
a cow it had been smoked a little dry
you said you saw a bro nutria and you
said no to the barbecue sauce too much
sugar so I might my cockles went up and
I went Brennan's on a new diet well
you're on a new diet a third a iet
what's what is it bro just life man but
no night of life no I understand that
they put something from me I eat it no
you fat girl and your mind your brain
you fat girl yeah chief a cheerleader no
no it's just it's just a little bit
below paleo vibe
Oh paleo because you you know I should
pay because you went a little crazy over
the past two weeks
well just cuz I was moving out of my
routine so if I go listen it's gonna be
on controlled environment for at two
weeks and I can't really work out cuz my
stuff's not set up yeah we're gonna go
yeah we get loose go crazy
I'm director now stick in my diet
tonight - bad day three I'm a little
lightheaded Phil all right though I try
to use zero sugar that is in the diet
and I feel like that isn't that isn't
the bikes you know I'm the sugar baby
yeah I was born of Shannara
you got a sweet sauce on your titties
sweet little mouth you guys yeah
I've always said you got a little sweet
mouth you got a sugar tits yeah bro you
got a shirt is mouth sugar - yeah you
you got a sweet and the guys at
Starbucks that one where I always feel
uncomfortable at cuz they look at me and
judge my body and asked me to suck their
dicks yes with their eyes not with their
mouths but with their eyes it's in your
eyes right there well they kind of here
go they go do you want cream on do you
want cream on doing hot cream in your
mouth oh wait I'll just put it in the
drink sure that do yeah little do a
little extra hey a little what happens
is no see I you bring out the giggle I
can't read between the lines cos I've
like last time he's like do you wanna
lecture cream in your shirt in your
coffee now is all I'm fine man and then
today I was a little confusing us do you
want me to come in your mouth okay I
don't know how it did I mean I feel like
that's not a different man cream Ellen
no I don't think use my copy waking that
house no I want to stick not oh my god
now I don't think
said that anyway that's pretty direct
yeah I'm still a confused you want me to
stick my credit card into the Machine
yeah the chip reader is absolutely not
no he said I want to bang you I want to
knock your mouth he said I want a man I
want a man bang you he said he was I
wanna [ __ ] start your skull okay
that's clear you're not into that okay
but it took them I'm having trouble
believing that I think what he does
though is he tends to get sassy with you
so he'll he'll he'll flirt hard so he'll
go why don't you get all the coffee like
he's not a great flirter he'll just say
something like oh yeah what's it gonna
be today
yeah that's sassy thing you never
actually did like Oh which once you get
all the coffee and then I'll go what do
you like do you have a dark roast right
now he's like we don't have dark enough
for you I'm like right well just yeah
let's just kind of tone it down a notch
there you go there you go I guess he
wants more now again next we yeah that
kind of stuff is so cute and then what
well it's like that you like the girl I
don't I grab and instead of saying that
you hit her it's that whether you pinch
my arm every time I walk in there yeah I
have to deal with that and then when
you're not there you guys ah did I see
Brian on TV I'm like yup he's a working
actor yes pretty sure I saw my Navy
ceiling again working actor we've been
over this twice now at least
but there's look every time when you're
in love with somebody and you could be a
little more charitable when you're in
love with something ladies don't want to
connect he's he's a big handsome he's a
he's a big man and he's a sweet man he's
very nice and he's a very good coffee
maker I feel it's not his fault it's not
his fault that you Amish are his a dream
I'm a sugar baby it's not his fault
well here's the ones I'll swim is a
shoulder to shoulder I want your dick
juice in my coffee don't want your sugar
my coffee I'm trying to start this diet
and they tried sabotaging it cuz he goes
triple shot almond milk latte for
Brendan not Brandon like yeah very funny
boom give it to me and he goes there's
even a lunch or something in there I'm
like alright well either just in this
which definitely don't want or he put an
extra shot
that'd be norm do you know what he put
in there bro you already put in there
mocha no that would been actually nice
yeah no man
caramel well this sugar baby is trying
to wean off the goddamn sugar good dog
it's delicious
tells me well he's my son do you know I
mean look at me and I'm being serious
these muscle do you know you knew out
that you know what a great boyfriend he
would be do you know that your meals
would be cooked every day do you know
that your clothing even your underwear
would be ironed do you know do you know
that he would have a special place for
you to sit and watch her next flick
stuff while he he'll arrest his head in
your lap and do you know that he would
always have that giant head on your
chest and fall asleep ahead like Fuji
they sure that he would brush your he
would brush your teeth you wouldn't have
to do a damn thing
do you understand that I don't know
yours I do that there's a few women also
you know that he would work extra hard
cuz he appreciates you so and you're
your mom and always be and I'm just
saying bro I don't mean to be crude but
your listen me I'm not I'm trying to be
code like but you're also an always
being do you know what I'm saying your
tongue tank would always be on nothing
I'm just saying your contact always be
on and what I'm saying is think about it
and stop being weird whoa who's that guy
that's what that guy who was sucking me
off looks like but white and gay yeah
there's probably dude how was your
weekend dude
well my weekend was tough you're in
Vancouver right my weekend was amazing
in Vancouver we sold out one night folk
theater I see Will Sasso was on there as
well sure was he was hilarious he played
well David Greco which was he had a bad
comic dude he had me die and one point
he had pages and he was like huh and he
was reading the joke and he as a
performer this [ __ ] is you don't
get that early really you don't get
better you don't get better I was
watching him with in awe he's just fun
assassins
oh so [ __ ] hot and they went crazy
little man you know it's Vancouver when
they but they went crazily gyah
he's like the Ron Burgundy of ink I had
a blonde walking legend in and out but I
had a plow just one show Friday or was
one show
Thursday's economy festival yeah comedy
fest so then did you fly back on Friday
go back home oh you're in town I thought
you for something that though you're
gone the whole weekend I was in town
yeah you you were super quiet because I
thought you
feelings were a little hurt weird I
think I'm Vancouver because I work
because Friday night I was at two shows
I had one with Rogen that one usually
when I don't hear from you I go very
quiet I know I know I thought you were
in Vancouver the whole time I came
around with the kids the whole weekend
that's it that's life is the wife
because the wife is in Atlanta doing
what I don't know just doing some stuff
she's busy with dude what Lana huh yeah
she's in Atlanta Wow you're gonna say or
no giant attractive black men with huge
pipe in Atlanta it's a chocolate it
here's not that it's a chocolate say it
it's not Vegas for black creates a
chocolate city and it works the
chocolate Mecca now in Atlanta I don't
want to get it I want to get into any of
it right now but I don't either but if
you've gun to my head yeah she was doing
but don't do that because she listens
and she gets mad dude whoa why are you
doing the wall rest you're doing the
walrus Washington oh that was the walrus
no no no Washington here
no all right so let's let's move on to
that but um about tough weekend though
our dear friend Brody Stephens who I've
known for 12 years
what a wonderful wonderful human being
that will caught me by surprise and I
said this on my show earlier in the
obviously you you guys doing way better
where it affects and not to make it
about me where affects me a lot is I can
see the pain and the hurt of all my
friends right everybody the economy
store Laugh Factory at the improv
everybody's affected by this because you
know Brody was the guy who made everyone
feel good yeah he was I was a fixture I
had no idea that he suffered from eating
this illness I didn't have a clue when I
saw Brody
he was always on I know when I first got
to the comment store whatever two three
years ago and I was I still do this day
I always feel like I'm out of place I
don't belong there he was always the I'm
always the guy who's so positive and
also thank yous are so wonderfully odd
about how about when I had that I had a
set in the belly room and he went on
after and I've never seen him do that
let's just straight up crowd work I see
assets whenever crowd work and he goes
on I was like it's what's going on right
now and they go you've never seen Brody
crowd we're come on
like this is hee-hee bombing goes nope
just wait and he turns the whole room
round I told you I came down what dude
[ __ ] Brody's deep note yeah I know I
remember that but you've known for a
live not ever ever and I did two movies
with him the hangovers we flew over to
Thailand together we used to perform in
don beerus is kennedy overdrive he had a
I was in I was in an air band that you
guys don't know about but but I was in
an air band for two years Don Barris is
Arab and I played all different
instruments and Brody played the drums a
lot of times he'd come out and start
playing the drums and Steve Rannazzisi
would get up and do a spot on Brody
impersonation it was it was a bummer
because I'd spoken to Brody
ten four days before that and he seemed
so fine he seems so great and I was
gonna do his podcast I was talking to
his producer about doing his podcast we
were texting back and forth did you know
I knew I didn't know I had no idea
I knew he I knew holy Hinchcliffe had
his issues like everybody but you don't
know this you never expect not to that
excuse me I'd no idea to this extent
really and Tony Hinchcliffe I think his
post and I've texted Tony this I thought
his post made the most sense because you
know everyone says your stuff from a
month to health you got to get help
stuff and all that stuff but you know
Tony kind of maps it out for everyone to
so Tony was on stage when they told
about this he's on there right in heels
the guy calls me was hey I got some bad
news thing is you can tell it like you
sure you wanna do this here so he tells
him so it ended early keep going though
because he goes he was on stage and he
said you got a call yeah a life calling
stays is a joke he said what happened
you sound like a friend died he said he
did and he said you want to tell me in
front of those people ain't took him off
speaker and said Brody died so yeah at
the end of said early yeah
keep going he talked about Brody
specifically that I keep going um
they're very long posted looks like let
me see Cubs dugout he talked about the
time Brody went to the psych ward and
they showed up supporting they started
doing jokes
keep going yeah
going yeah keep going it might be
glimpses time chance like I keep going
keep going
mental health is a very real thing man
mental I just thought the egos too big I
chose figure Brodie he talks about how
he's you like he had the medication he
was going through therapy he had all the
friends in the world we just don't know
how to help some people and that's the
truth and we have we're limited right
now on how to help people who suffer
from depression and anxiety and suicide
there's another post equation the first
one is the second part I would I would
imagine if you asked a lot of people
that committed suicide why they wouldn't
know either they wouldn't have an answer
for you it's just oh here it goes Tony
who's a phenomenal writer put this is
usually the part where the person would
say if you know anyone with depression
call them tell them you love them blah
blah blah well yeah that's true but we
did that with Brody he was on medicine
had great doctors and a slew of people
that care deeply about him so it's not
that I guess if there's something to
take away from all this it's exactly how
serious of a disease it is even when
someone is loved and cared for medically
we need to start really accepted mental
illness as a disease like we think of
cancer something that doesn't always
kill you but if you let if left
untreated and it still can be treated
yeah yeah he's right as somebody who's
has dealt with it in their own family
and stuff it's it's very frustrating and
it's very very hard because there are
times when you just don't know you don't
know what to do you you you as a person
can't help them and it's it sucks and I
still relate to it all because it you
know I don't know anything about I don't
suffer from there I'm sure some of my
friends do but it's like I don't know
what to do somebody so cuz that with
that when I happen with Rosie I told Rob
I go do don't you feel like because we
have to improv together and right before
when I go dude don't you feel like if
you would have known about Brody could
just went over there save them and
rhodos doesn't work like doesn't work
like that
he's you know you know he goes I'm done
you can't so we were talking about this
a while back about suicide and a guy who
I who comes from
shows periodically I think in Seattle
and a really good guy but he texts he DM
me and he said let me explain to you
what suicidal feelings are he said if
you've ever been to an in a sauna and it
gets too hot yeah and you just get out
because it's too hot he goes that's what
it feels like but there's nowhere to go
you can't breathe and I went they said
yeah he said I and and so the only thing
that you feel you can do is just push
the exit button yeah it's like I was
like oh my god gingka power do you think
about that does narrow I know you must
have been so bad for him to do that
things was in his mind must've been so
bad and hopefully he's not suffering
anymore and wherever he's at now but
it's like it's such a [ __ ] shame man
yeah that that's that's serotonin levels
that's who knows man who knows what it
is you know I don't know I don't know
but but I think that the reality of
certain things we know is that we'll
deal with this well we'll always be
dealing with this until they can figure
out a way to reverse engineer the brain
or something but until they can figure
out what exactly happens to people I
don't so Sam tripley's doing a benefit
March 5th at The Comedy Store and he you
know obviously he's gonna have off
cody's friends others who are the best
comedians in the world so I I told Sam
and Rome like I don't know how to help
all my friends turn out on how to help
so the only thing I knew I do you know
like I can make me nasty shirts so I'm
making a t-shirt to give all the staff
and that's a really climax it's a pretty
dope Brodie shirt just really really I
don't know what else to do what's that's
all I can do right now yeah I don't so I
can do heavy heart done man I could
adapt I just can't fathom play d1
baseball just Arizona State pitcher yeah
you know I was when they free I went
Todd Phillips director Todd Phillips who
cast him in the hangover Todd Phillips
saw him do that eight one eight till I
died and Todd was like [ __ ] man I gotta
get him in my motel I die Brian counts
coming up to the stage he like me was in
the hangover The Hangover anyone
recognized me no great alright eight one
eight late
gentleman Bryan Callen that's how he who
is [ __ ] cake so hilarious read and
then how about he would be he would do
all the crowd work from the Chelsea
Lately show oh yeah for all the you
you'd be the if you if you've ever been
in one of those crowds if you know it's
like to be a cold opener for a crowd
that doesn't want to be there
I forget who told this story some really
good comic I apologize should not
remember he said they did an industry
night and I think was at the Laugh
Factory the improv and all the comics
comics you would know huge and comics
bombed because it's just filled with in
agents agents who were just there and I
think they're better and they said all
the biggest names in the world bomb yeah
and then Brody's going up next they go
good luck man it's the worst guy ever
he's goes right at him and completely I
can boom the room I got a stereo love so
we're on we're doing a hangover too and
Zach Galifianakis myself and Bradley
Cooper everybody it's a huge scene
there's a helicopter and everything else
in Brody it's when it's when the main
guy gets taken down and it turns out
that Brody and all the guys around them
are actually cops it's a sting operation
the they arrest what the [ __ ] is a child
ciao everybody and so so so they
basically the helicopter comes up and
produce stevens zach goes watch brody
because as as you know you're supposed
to be a cop you pull out your gun right
there amazed you know that so as as the
helicopter comes up and everything comes
out Brody has his hips out he's low and
his hands are pushing toward and I go so
the next take I go what are you doing
bro and he goes I'm guarding him I know
what I mean he was you know how you
doing basketball I'm making sure he
doesn't get away so Brody's literally
looks like he's guarding a guy you know
you guard a guy yeah like you're
guarding a guy I was laughing so hard
housing and I it began the sort of the
thing I go okay so you're a cop say you
don't want to do this so I was giving
him acting lessons but the greatest
thing about him and his his innocence
and his beauty is he'd be like hey can
you teach me he he was so open about it
he had no ego no [ __ ] ego at all he
just asked you a question how would I do
this in this situation I was like just
make sure it doesn't go anyway
oh yeah he was really unique he made
Zach Galifianakis laugh harder does that
called me when somebody goes Brody
Stephens is the funniest person to hang
out with him and I got a call the next
day I'm Brody cuz Zach Brody Stephens
after last night I feel like we're ready
to take our friendship to the next level
okay bye bye yeah he was great and he
exactly bring Brody up after his after
Brody would bring Zach up and that could
be like Brody just got a his own TV show
on the smelling Channel oh so big such a
shame it's an outrage it's such a [ __ ]
you
Oh Zach did the Brody Stevens interview
can we watch that for a second [ __ ]
Zach is this when Zach had that beard Oh
Zach so funny
Brody's team is the interview challenge
Zach out have a seat all right pleasure
the sake between two ferns bad waiter
why would you like some wine sir yes
that's how I would pour it you have like
sweat I mean that's not your problem I
don't know how you have super glue
underneath that huge shaded swimming
with sunglasses at the in Malibu the
other day and what happened would you
see out there I thought I saw a shark
really because there's a lot of sharks
going on but it was careful it was Brody
doing the backstroke the interview is
great the best part is when they're just
the it was like between two ferns
it's a shark I saw a shark but it was
probably doing the backstroke
hilarious mmm that was funny
yeah that's what he was to everybody
like everybody like well look at all
that look at the pouring out crime
port and how much everyone loves them
yeah and I he's also like there's some
comics you know people whether it's true
or not might talk some [ __ ] about them
or there's jealousy or shade there's
none of that with Brody no hear anyone
say a bad word about rody ever never I
don't think people put up with it if he
did yeah
and for Julia to post something this was
my favorite cut it was only because
Brody yeah he's great he's great
oh there it is John Roy but there's a
charity show at the lab for a future
show of major Hollywood agency audience
was all agents who were forced to go
there by their work on Tuesday that's
who I was referring to I know Johnny
yeah his story was great on there he
helped you up man yep yep yep and so it
goes brother and so it goes
life goes on doesn't it you had my son's
birthday party on Saturday really at the
sky Zone the trampoline place it's fun
my son place is dangerous oh yeah oh
yeah it is these are dangerous well if
they don't have them well protected it
like we rented out an area right so just
for his friends for his bday but there
was a area in the mat where I was like
dude there's a huge hole here cop my kid
could easily slide through they go oh
[ __ ] sorry I had to move us I come on
let's figure this out
right there that's all sit good grandal
so some of the dad's to get way too
serious like it was their release and
playtime Beauty party sort of jumping
around hurting kids so that was fun
I rented a spider-man who apparently
spider-man decided to stop fighting
crime for a short while yeah but himself
go OK and he's a fan of the devil's
dandruff you told me that all that it's
about a 47 year old spider-man at least
yeah it's many bad decisions in his life
it's a tough one
yeah I told you when I had the
highlights at man my son had Pirates of
the Caribbean and the guy was speaking
in the terrible accent like this he was
from England but it was Ted I was like
you need to get a I was judging the [ __ ]
out of every to every one of their
performances can you put a little effort
into it here's that to me I find it
depressing I don't want to rent
my girl Wrentham I didn't isolate this
what you get we paid $75 for spider-man
for seven hours correct of course that
correct so that's my face so until you
picture this because I must be happy in
that in that outfit I was trying to feed
my son and he would not [ __ ] whoa
Pizza you got a pizza cuz you want being
big and healthy like smart rent get your
beats I want dude calm okay I'm face how
do get my son like dude cuz I I and I
told aspiring like dude you have to ten
I need you in a four for the kid you're
scaring everybody my son's I can eat
then you go oh no problem dude
there you go [ __ ] cucumbers lettuce
tomatoes mushrooms how do you want to be
super-hearing like inspiron didn't talk
like that bro I don't know what that is
that's not Peter Parker yeah you said
the next round out he's getting crappy
of doing that he crashed our oh yeah
we'll see what happens it only lasts 45
minutes well he snuffed enough of it to
last a solid hour ish and then it
crashed hard
I found a mask half up sweating
profuseiy I go you want a jumpy us nah
man I don't jump we will we're paying
for him we need you like it look likes
primers so just kind of stick and jump
on the wall yes no that's one thing I
don't do I don't jump man what all right
we've had enough of spider and we can go
home yeah that's fine
did the more lecture yeah tip a little
ass where you got a tip got a tip well
was good he can't get a teacher he came
to he came to Hollywood expect him to be
[ __ ] Bradley Cooper yeah and then
some along somewhere along the way that
just didn't get the breaks Bradley got
somebody sent me the talent issue
well somebody sent me a video of a movie
I did that I'd never watched when I was
32 years old
oh what's it called it's called a fish
without a bicycle do you have it sure do
it's on YouTube oh look that up Jedi I
watched it when we get kicked off June
bride oh no hard working but let's just
look at it I don't I think so we might
not but um I was like that was that was
mm I shot it in 2000 maybe even 1989 and
Baelor know I'm in the whole movie I can
find so you'll be in the trailer right I
don't know let's say click that dude it
was young young people seem to be into
it has 800 abuse
and your little time to move yourself
we're gonna go find yourself there you
know so I have a lot of scenes in for
love long single the wrong places but to
see myself at 32 by the way I was cute
too this is in theaters and the only
thing harder than finding a man he's
funny
that's my friend Jenna Madsen who is
great she's a tall but she wrote it you
wanna see my etchings
but what Julianna's looking for might
not be what she needs this is so cheesy
didn't watch the movie so I don't know
write your way it was funny how I had
shot that movie and spent a while doing
it and I never watched it and 18 years
later somebody on instagram sent it to
me and I went oh my god Ryan a green
horse Brian calories I mean they did you
already two years old brother did I'll
show you the scenes in your life I'll
show you my resolution I love it will
just be like that was me by the way a
full head of hair different face I had a
different value a 20 years ago I was I
was a cute guy
yeah then father time goes cute faith
let's let's make the nose more bulbous
let's make every well let's just droop
your face mean I mean because I was I
look at myself and I was like well I was
a cutie pie that's a life ghost like I
woke up this morning fought I'm it you
don't hold on there I'm gonna give you
two bags under your eyes yeah look I hit
and it only gets worse your skin gets
thick or something happens as you get
older and you're like man man oh man
z-man Paulo are you gone daesil of hair
on your shoulders yeah we went along
here in your ears yeah and daddy fights
it daddy fights it hard daddy's always
fighting gravity never stops training
working this air assault I got an air
assault treadmill
yeah loving it for my boys ugh oh man
running my dick off on that and so if my
legs look thick if I look tighter than
normal it's my aerosol Papa's me start
act up I've done seven days on the
peloton I think seven days in a row
might be got the old the old knew it
what are you doing yeah you can you not
run anymore cuz the old easy peasy
I can run once a week once a week just
once a week now yeah because the reason
that I got that Air Assault is because
it it's like really easy I can run on
the air so yeah I'm talking you know
easy I like to go old school and go on
the roads I love running on the road
okay but greyhounds aren't me you ever
seen a greyhound running on the road
sure Hank sure Hank you see a greyhound
run at the dog park yeah no there's a
reason for that oh yeah because to be
Hertz the joint yeah well this old
greyhound gets the brain of a chihuahua
you like to move bro you move you run I
run but they leave I like I like about
that because they're curved up those air
assaults bring that out for a section
and and it's self-powered and it's so
easy I look like a tank tire yeah I
guess it makes you it designed to make
you run properly and I wanna get the
aerosol bicycle that's why I wrestle but
you want to come over and get your sweat
game yeah that's a [ __ ] right
here I get a whole gym at the crib now
bro bring up the trash you come over and
then after I destroy on there salt in
the [ __ ] treadmill I will go up and
play on my basketball court not dunk my
nuts dude I would love to play you and
basketball how about we do a dunk
contest I [ __ ] in your mouth okay I'm
being here I guess you ever had a
two-hand dunk in a turd in your mouth
that's so it's so aggressive see that
that's the air assault now listen me
right now I'll outrun you all [ __ ]
day do we you don't want that no no all
[ __ ] aside remember almost nothing
and brought in for the improv you said
race we had lost sprint to Penn - yeah
you did beat me in that but as far as
like long distance long this my show
your mouth
well it's my shining though dude you get
your [ __ ] your finger [ __ ] get
your fingers out at your photo
don't [ __ ] it'll piss me off I beat
you I'll beat you I'll put 80 miles on
that thing right now I'm still working
up to it but I'm gonna get I'm gonna get
I'm gonna be a [ __ ] runner and God
help anybody who steps in the ring with
me I'm about to work dude I still want
to do a [ __ ] marathon
campaigns like let's do it brother Mike
there's steps to this game brother I'm
gonna try and do a hundred million miles
in the [ __ ] you want to do it you
want to do a marathon marathon I feel
like you're so big that it's gonna hurt
your knees if you do if you love em much
shut the [ __ ] you know I mean though you
were the big breaks down run dude you
break one day I'd be good especially
like train for it all so that's the
reason I'm losing a little weight I can
run longer Oh at the end of the day the
big man breaks down he's gotta go
upstairs and go to bed no what no I
don't do you do your back you know I
started doing recently what drinking a
wine at night I get myself a nice bottle
menage-a-trois yeah don't I just [ __ ] it
anymore yeah and you're like a beep like
a baby makes you feel good I jump in
that tub
give my balls soaked in that tub drink
the [ __ ] top then I little CBD well
under the tongue really out yeah
Sleeping Beauty baby so so I talked to
this guy Derek who works with craig
venter who is if one of the guys who's
involved in longevity drugs and
synthetic biology I mean he's top of the
food chain in extending our by a snake
oil and no just kidding like stem cell
yeah I can't either for real
and he goes um but he goes after all the
research is still nothing competes with
enough sleep good food and exercise it
did [ __ ] off at game set match you gotta
sleep and you got a drink water please
got it the most important doll so dad
works out like a madman but if you
actually want to lose weight 90 percents
your diet correct 90 percent yeah it's
better if you just ate right and didn't
work out yeah that'd be the way to get
well you know the other thing that I I
want to sock you in the face right I
want it I want it Wow because my wife
shall lately sure man brother yeah sure
it looks pretty cool like how you do
this with your jaw where are you going
now what is that
peekaboo oh no what that's what you hear
what I'm punching you and I'm not
kidding do did you hear a boy Dustin
Poirier you got a fight who's he
fighting see you're not friends with him
bro you when he's my he's my dad I'm off
with your feet hacks to me right now hey
Dustin no you're not oh yeah who's he
fighting
ah there it is I know he's fighting yep
Tony nope I know I know he's fighting
whoo-hoo what did you say yeah I'm
waiting for you it's fighting compete
definitely not getting that for a sec
you know that what's it what do you want
to know
yep want to know one more shoe is he
fighting it for 5 at 55 55 yeah pounders
uh he will be fighting 100% dogs running
damn it again close but no do you want
one more tired I'd like one more try
Adam or try it's not Edson Barboza
definitely not not gonna make any sense
now would make no sense
it'd have to be a guy who's who's up
there top of the food chain if I put my
thinking cap on I'm gonna know right
away now we have various guys we've got
Paul Felder well hey big fights bro yeah
big fights builder also has one lung and
still in the hospital so he's just one
long long burst
oh no why old news keep guessing man
hold on dude am I is an intriguing fight
dude if you say Chuck Liddell I'm gonna
rip your [ __ ] nose off a horse Gracie
is it gonna be is it gonna be is it
gonna be a is it intriguing am I gonna
be excited is data 5000 intrigue
immemorial all right hold on hold on
hold on why am I having trouble why am I
having it's max Holloway max always
coming up that's a home run [ __ ] I knew
that you're a beat max how's Riley a big
name fight this is Corey for our boy
this is shut up Dustin Poirier that's
only because I love max oh well do two
great boxers great spiders damn it do
you want to punch you in the dick today
I don't know what it is why don't you
[ __ ] ball your fists off and suck me
right in my own [ __ ] 3-piece shut
come on it's come on let me squeeze it
up I'll get all hernia and you [ __ ]
socket and wash my face not change I'm
saying guys like god dad let's say
you'll hear me do as I'm herniating my
nuts Bulldog your nuts
I would Bulldog my nuts right now if
there are only guys in this room for the
camera might just pull off you know I
would do it but no I don't mind anybody
can see my balls
there yeah yeah a big set of balls on
you cats grossed out they're gonna say
cats balls
Fuzzy's give some cats balls look she's
right you got boom I got balls yeah dude
you definitely did I was gonna say did
you watch the Oscars didn't I don't
watch it speaking of balls you know Adam
Lambert who is the lead singer of Queen
now now that our boy Freddie Mercury
passed away looks like him too I've
definitely done it so he premiered he
was the open the the intro for the
awards I feel like Freddie Mercury's
even like dude you gotta take it down a
notch you're too gay from me like he is
ah like if there's a if there's a if the
if gays were at a league he'd be the law
okay guys well he's Jerry way hey guys
like your friends what a la gay guys
like dude can I see that can I see a
little bit we watch it but what prof
that did it all I say play to a clip for
Brian with just so we're not tied for
that show but doesn't sound like freddie
mercury's all day that much nobody does
one come on he's got a little bit of my
voice like this ah yep you're like
Freddie Mercury's like damn dude you
yeah well you took he takes get Freddie
Mercury he went Freddie let me hope I
get a little bit ready you're acting gay
hold my beer yeah Kiki I'm a little
embarrassed but that's okay
I was true I'm embarrassed when ha you
bridesmaid can play that guitar brother
dude you didn't hear your boy Brad
Cooper sing oh I get that I got a say
got a happy kid [ __ ] first time ever
seen from like crowd you got you think
you'd be [ __ ] nervous
he sent a couple days ago actually know
about a week or two he performed with
Lady Gaga at one of her car to get ready
for this right now gun to the head have
they [ __ ] before
look at me Brian look at me look at me
can't look at me okay yes oh god it's
trending everywhere here so doesn't she
yeah guys [ __ ] straight up dude now
he done cheat on his diet he does not
know he's too disciplined friend to
correct yourself doesn't she done I
guarantee that [ __ ] straight as
an arrow
yeah in every way to shooting his load
straight into Lady Gaga's way
it's such a great song this movies even
more sad when thing about Brody
[Music]
phenomenal movie I'd be nervous
me too yes for kids huh crapping has one
kid really just one the out song of the
year but he's great
Lady Gaga sighs this I've never stared
at anyone the way these Tuesday I've
done some [ __ ] in my day ladies dude
they don't break eye contact all this is
the part where I was like they might be
[ __ ] me put away this mic it's
Bradley Cooper a [ __ ] movie star or
what he's the biggest in the world
[ __ ] the King now look at this
they're just doing it is the only award
they won my mother [ __ ] was for the best
yeah they won't give it up to him it's
too good-looking they won't give it up
Wow I saw that to hold some of the
awards the awards were definitely
different
no there was and yep definitely a more
interesting I mean more urban vibe is
cool though more urban vibe hmm it's
cool though
got you mm-hmm black panther did very
well I want to see what the ratings are
on that I want to see what the ratings
without Kevin Hart I'm telling all those
people crying very low tweets you [ __ ]
up man yeah because now it ruins the
Awards of course it does that was by far
the best part of the night yeah five not
even close yeah everything else suck
yeah when you're being an activist when
you're pushing a social agenda as
opposed to just honoring Molinari nine
point six billion that's it just kidding
that's pretty sounds pretty good Spike
Lee won of course I'm glad finally I
didn't see black Klansmen though oh
that's a good movie is it takes place in
my home you don't want to see close tie
your green book is [ __ ] great have
you seen it I haven't got a watch that I
hear great things oh my that's soloist
the solo the documentary or the guy
climbs the [ __ ] oh yeah keep that one
oh man I gotta watch that this one green
book and solo
yeah yeah t-cell oh you'll love solo I
watch amazing um watch both now can I
see green book on Netflix or no no it's
still in the theater okay and then our
boy who played Freddie Mercury Remy he
won best man yeah he won though what the
one who won the the female could not she
walked in right now was like hey anyone
want churros I'm like who are you oh
yeah that was for what's it called
The Reckoning or what's it called how
the favorite the favorite you won't see
that - is that her see that common to
see and I haven't the favorite I don't
have too much did you see it no I've saw
most the movies that were up for awards
I love the award I used to work them
free oh yeah I love them yeah I love
reading that goes into it I love all
that stuff I don't because I'm not part
of them that's how I am yeah it's a
video no we don't need video yeah but
that was the best part Lady Gaga she was
the first actress or talent ever up for
Best Original Song and Oscar for acting
good for her crazy right
she's unstoppable she's phenomenal I
also hear from people who that know her
and work with her that she's an awesome
person she's just grown was a big one
that's on Netflix I heard it was
unwatchable from some people a little
that was great yeah yeah I don't know
weird Regina King one she was good she
want I love her oh did you see vice know
we're Dick Cheney and not I know I wanna
see that - oh the doc you so that some
of the documentaries keep going down the
dunt features so I haven't see I want to
see
I think of fathers and sons almost in
minding the gap a fathers and sons
it's about Isis and that yeah pretty
sure it's some dark [ __ ] I'd really like
to see that animated feature film you
bet your sweet ass spider verse one well
you know what I found out about like the
certain people that have know better you
got that like um a lot of these movies
about Isis now that's a documentary you
know zero dark thirty yeah love that
movie yeah every time thought you know
it's all [ __ ] though that the CIA
gave cat from what I understand gave
Kathryn Bigelow like a whole lot of
goods so they told her one thing she had
inside sources but what they do is they
they hoodwink you they'll give you a
[ __ ] amazing story who's they easy
and all that all that all the CIA people
start to the SEAL team guys whoever who
are we who you referred to here oh she's
the writer she was the director and okay
right it's right okay carry on so what
they'll do is they you know you go in
and people talk but you want to know how
they captured bin Laden do you know that
they can't give you art facts but we but
in fact it was considered like people
are like you know pure up in arms like
you can't tell people this this is
[ __ ] people were pissed about the
hood where they treated the ISIS like
the it was also not how they captured it
then a lot and that's what I'm saying
that's not how they did it no no not at
all that's what they told the media and
it's just that's what they told Kathryn
Bigelow on them and they thought they
were they thought they were the point is
that Kathryn Bigelow and then thought
they were actually doing a movie that
was true they thought that they were
they were that the research they did was
was an accurate depiction of everything
about how they captured bin Laden and it
wasn't at all so they really still
oppression yeah when you go to those
guys and you go hey and they're like
yeah I'll tell you what they're not
telling you and I guess that's what
that's how I was surprised at do you
know how they caught him I have I have
an idea yes I was told catfished him
damn that's what they do you have you
really you have an idea yeah I mean I a
little bit of one like what I understand
I'm not gonna say all right Eddie Bravo
no I was told I mean I'm not gonna but I
I don't know any but I don't know the
answers but the answer is no now that is
true the helicopters 1d crash there was
a team of seals that went in there they
did shoot him uh yeah that's aw yeah the
big
question is yes but how how they finally
was there find them and they have dad a
different way they had been working on
that for a year in a different way
but I just thought it was interesting I
was like oh yeah that makes sense of
course Oh whenever zero dark thirty I
like that movie ouch it's a great movie
I liked it is this like a list of facts
and yeah bunch of articles on X but when
it came out at first it was like you
know there's such [ __ ]
you know what movie I watched last night
too was a quiet place I love that how
great was that man - good movie how
great and moving in the end like moves
oh good so good he kills himself for the
kids
dude hey he's been out you need to stop
being Johnny Chan dude that the quiet
place came out a year ago you're right
but still I put now I want to see this
you're not a year ago no the second
one's gonna come out he was i he was
fantastic it was a me know he wrote and
directed that yeah man he's amazing and
then he put his girl in it - my movies
great beginning is very rough the movies
great oh you know true detective season
three I heard it's amazing
uh-huh have you been watching it no I
stopped watching a season two is so
awful but I love season one but everyone
tells you season three is better than
one they fixed so now I'm back on HBO
although dish don't have HBO right now
that that's the guy from gradebook yeah
he won it's a second in two years good
actor phenomenal actor Stephen Dorff -
yeah I need a watch for Stephen Dorff
he's been quiet for a while he's awesome
since blade he's a good guy good guy
I haven't see him do anything since bleh
I'm glad that that guy I'm glad that
that happened that's really cool for him
his true detectors like in the high
boards because I don't have HBO it's
just you're competing with Netflix and
so many other things yeah and so is Game
of Thrones Game of Thrones goes Netflix
hold my [ __ ] drag is the only show
good yeah no not true detective doesn't
feel like it made I haven't really heard
people talking about narcos have you am
i absolute narcos sucked the third
season sorry Todd Feldman the third
season in Mexico there's no one like in
season one you've got
Pablo right season two you got El Chapo
yeah
season three goes back on how I'll chop
up KML chopped like it goes everything
but you just know what to root for
you're not rooting for a bad guy you
there's no no it's just not yeah it's
just not there the the fun isn't there
right you'd like there's no one you
don't hate anyone you don't care you
just don't care about the characters
you're right it's a bummer to man cuz I
[ __ ] love narcos I love that the
first one was just dude the second one's
amazing - first and second are amazing
second one's the third one it's just
it's just missing that villain that that
lovable villain you're right and I love
the young I love the actor what's the
guy Pena
yeah he's great Michael Pena I love him
he's great it's not his fault it's just
it's not there the story's not this
doesn't it's not funny
hmm wait how to do Andreea one dog yeah
it's just not there though man but true
detective I don't know it's just not in
height because I don't have HBO right
now or never it's easy one was huge
season 2 everyone jumped the ship goes
so bad God it was bad yeah uh wonder if
season 3 has the same riders a season 1
remember yeah so what happened was I
think the writer the director one of the
guys went away and the other guy was
trying to take credit and he's not the
guy it was I can't remember the guy was
there was a political thing going on I
don't think Chin's gonna find it I was
looking at this stuff
his Oh lotto mm-hmm
I don't know he's a hard [ __ ] miss
right yeah tough tough huh
to some current event you have to do it
sure
wait you want to do this one first
oh my God thank this is yours cat mm-hmm
your self this was so [ __ ] funny have
you seen the Instagram of it yeah so ja
rule performed at a game where it was
Minnesota versus Milwaukee he performed
the halftime show and it didn't go well
there were some technical difficulties
and the crowd just didn't seem to care
that ja Rule was performing and either
did the players no because he tried to
hype up the crowd while there was some
type of technical difficulties just
trying to buy time and when he was
trying to hype up the crowd there was
little to no response from anybody and
he was trying it was 90s night so he was
saying that oh they hired me for 99 but
I'm early I'm a 2011 mm oh well do this
thing yeah and nobody responding he's
like are you ready and then after like
ten solid seconds of nobody responding
he's like guess not and he performs the
show
towards the end players just get on to
the station of course start shooting
that isn't performing are you sure no
I've been there but not on that scale
how this girl fell all right let's see
this they said this is 90 tonight so
they brought out of 2000 artists put my
album came out 99 so I guess that counts
Sanchez we ready
I guess not he's gone it's kids in shape
oh boy oh my god there's this when the
players started coming out onto the
court
[Music]
the crowd just don't give that's really
not a that's a thankless Krauts right on
to corporate gigs anymore he put what
gig do I'm gonna do he where now he put
genre but y'all really be on my dick
let's be clear my sound was [ __ ] up at
first and didn't come on what it was
supposed to but I rocked that [ __ ]
thanks for the love Milwaukee great win
my streak continues
I'm good fear y'all act like this is not
an old halftime shows y'all mad corny
for this post oh because they I guess
the crack in here is his mic is what
he's saying yeah well he does have some
me I mean I'd be Jam a little bit if
though ya know they pried out oh yeah he
also tried to put a curse on the team on
the Timberwolves cuz they tried to troll
him on Twitter me but you just jinx
yourself talking to God this way your
curse now you won't want to championship
for the next 30 years and cat is leaving
apologize and I'll lift the curse
speaking of ja Rule and town and fire
the fire first of all I had dinner with
Travis Travis from blink 182 what a
great guy what a [ __ ] great guy yeah
he says how do you think what a cool
what a smart classy dude really cool um
job role put a curse on his own career
like what's he been doing for the last
20 years right he just doesn't me it's
no man maybe just gave it up dude yeah
he said he said he doesn't fly against
Travis which I didn't know do you know
what yeah oh yeah definitely not know
yeah why what did he get yeah no he was
with that he was did you can't be seein
the jam yellows friends dog walk I
didn't know that he at least yeah that's
why he's all those tattoos all over his
mom oh my god when he said that I
thought to myself I wonder and it rang a
bell but I wasn't sure
oh he'll even take a ship over if they
do a Europe tour these kids leave like a
month or Tom oh my god that's what kind
of like he was like waiting for the cash
I guess and they just were like me mom
but oh I forgot about that I'm glad I
didn't bring that up I'm glad I didn't I
I thought about asking why I didn't fly
and then I'm glad I didn't that guy
survived though so the to policy
survives arrived but yeah
yeah had a drug is very very sad super
the whole thing said oh he got really
badly burned and stuff
III didn't third-degree burns all over
his body his foot they thought they
don't have to amputate yeah that's all
back everything that's why I said to
Solvers bah Jesus Christ man one of the
nicest guys on the planet great dude oh
he's great P East working out a beast
and some of the best cardio I think
we're always John's had him in the top
hundred top 50 best drummers of all time
when rolling sister when Roy says my top
ten Travis Barker monster yeah that's
his jet oh my god what and he talked
about what he talked to the story on
Rogan so the jet was on fire he gets out
he thinks everyone's okay
and his entire body because the way he
went out he got doused with a jet fuel
so his whole body's on fire because he
went through the jet fuel on accident
when he's he's just discombobulated had
to get out gets covered in the [ __ ]
fuel so he's on fires foots on fire and
he's just burning alive then here at
Sohn yell stop drop and roll he started
[ __ ] rolling but his foot I think it
was his left foot got the most damage
the entire body burned thirty degree
burns oh yes Jesus Christ you know lost
his leg oh well you don't talk about djm
there's a whole documentary that I think
Showtime did it he went he doesn't he
didn't talk about it doesn't deal with
it can't imagine was my best friend
nothing to talk about there's just a lot
of fly planes either man I'm already
scared as is me too well that yeah I
love Travis Barker though what else yet
so some people are angry at Adam Levine
for taking off his shirt during the
Superbowl boy
no because Janet Jackson was banned
after just never like ripped off her
shirt I agree how about that good women
should only be allowed to take their
shirts off get your tits out
I got cooler I got you a level playing
field get I got a zero problem with it
latter may not say shake your tip what's
good for men I like to say I was one of
this what's good for man is good for
women why why can't who says tits are
sexual
who
says that women can't show their tits in
public [ __ ] off that's a puritanical law
I'm with them if that [ __ ] mr.
Kim can be shirtless then girls can to
free the tits I said it I don't care I'm
a liberal
yeah feelings upset I meet your tip you
know in this category I'm a progressive
left-wing [ __ ] I want to see
tits show me you did yeah that was
pretty much the extent of the story CBS
was actually fine half a million dollars
for her nipple coming out oh wow that is
hilarious
then this person from the FCC put cm
Levine's nipples were repulsive also the
fact that it hasn't been an immediate
backlash like Jenny checked it it's that
it is just serving sexist and I bet this
girl you said that who said that FCC out
of the FCC I bet you get zero dick
that's why I find it offensive and she's
some tattooed guy's nipples on TV it was
my family it's not right how come when a
black MIT woman does it they're just
being provocative I love it I love it
America yes women should be allowed to
be shirtless what's the problem man if
guys aren't that got me all hot doctor
says I got jealous and I said FCC also
received almost two dozen complaints
from [ __ ] of families who were upset
that their children had to watch a
trailer for the Jordan Peele us movie
he should have a formal apology for
showing his nipples and horrible tattoo
choices I'm like a lot people are such
[ __ ] what else you have anything else
to do is there anything else to do with
your time how busy are you oops if
Beyonce came out showing her [ __ ] I
want it ready complaint I'd like all
right if that's what she wants to know
I'm praying that Kraft oh my god how
about Robert Kraft all he did was help
somebody with their rent do it gets
dicey dude what did you did you look
into a cat yeah so the owner of the
Patriots Robert Kraft was caught on film
paying first um paying for what they're
saying is sex at this I guess it's a
massage parlors called he work its of
Asia that's called rub and tug yeah and
people are surprised not necessarily
that he got a prostitute was that he got
a prostitute at this little place in a
strip mall yeah and so he got caught and
right now we're trying to see if he's
gonna get a second degree misdemeanor or
first degree misdemeanor either way he's
gonna be five given everybody's fingers
[ __ ] you
he's got a lot of money next time have
them come to your house of course but
it's like alright so he paid for sex
what a crime it's mostly the story is
with the actual spa itself there were
ten spas I got shut down because all of
the women were human trafficking victims
from China yeah that's what they say the
problem they're saying that is the human
trafficking with the China as they
promised them one thing I guess they got
here like they're promised yeah that's a
common story that's been the case for a
long time yeah yeah I don't know how
involved mr. Krafft was but he got his
if you just own the place that was
getting sucked off every time went to
Palm Beach he got his he got rubbed down
and had his nuts tugged this isn't Miami
doesn't mean he's Pro that doesn't mean
he's pro trafficking he's just pro girl
and likes having sex okay and he's got
money to pay for it cuz he's old that's
that's what I mean so seventy-seven yes
getting sucked off on I would be like
this it was well you went to all the
Oscar parties last night okay yes good
good good but but they are issuing a
warrant for his arrest he has to fly to
Palm Beach did it alright I'm sure it's
gonna be fine it's his first offense you
know I spread you're down there sniff it
out back and back in the day they'd be
like mr. Graff I'm really sorry to
bother you go ahead get out of here now
well that's kind of what they're doing
that's it there yeah
depends how involved he is yeah I think
it's terrible I won't stand for outrage
I'm gonna go down there I'm gonna
interview each and every one of these
ladies you should do that call arrive at
night y'all big round a stage over so
I'd say that there are no cameras in
there anymore so you know I want to talk
to them about fitting in in America yeah
a lot of those places in ly from what I
hear I don't watch time out what else
get alright there's an update to uh
Chris burrows you remember that guy the
newscaster the local news guy that oh
the local illa LA guys
the hotel and just randomly died right
yeah Brian assumed his foul play I think
I agree with that yeah you know our
sniffers are back out yeah this is
really sad too but oh no yeah everything
you guys imagined was basically true yet
eaten by crocodile no no so they found
out that he was having sex with a guy
yeah but it gets even crazier he met
this guy on a grinder app he's had sex
with him multiple times he stuck meth in
his ass two pieces of rocks in his ass
while they were having sex and then he
passed out started vomiting and passing
out yeah how crazy is this madness well
it's a bummer to die that way
does he have a family yes here's a
daughter here's a why he was gay either
that's just his only 43 you guys not
have never ever seen he's fair the
family that detail that's the thing that
sucks so bad [ __ ] you [ __ ] you media for
doing that like just the guy likes to
put he's got a daughter [ __ ] off man
she's got to see that the rest of her
life
I don't Rosa that [ __ ] I hate I know
that he did that but I hate that his
daughter I know yes I don't think we
need to know we don't need to another
thing we need we don't need to know I
don't think I need to know how Brody
Stephens been no guy I don't think
anyone needs them I don't think you
deserve that this guy spent how much
time from the camera he's like the main
anchor in LA everyone who has decency
decency and protect us protect his
[ __ ] um you know his privacy in in
death you know like come on man
for first first also get rotties do you
have to say Burl's inserted two rocks
into his ass yeah it's like some rocks
oh [ __ ]
who's the guy who's the [ __ ] who
wrote this [ __ ] you variety and margot
spiel [ __ ] her too simple Marva Smith
[ __ ] her and they're following their job
they don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] you yeah
still man like can you be a little bit
more you could have a conversation in
the [ __ ] Edit in the in the editing
room or whatever it is and and and and
talk to each other be like it's like be
like this he's got a wife and a child
[ __ ] you don't have to do dude let's the
protect this privacy that mean that cops
released the report I mean that's I know
I'm not I'm sure but
it would be better if it was private but
but did the family release it does the
family have a cell the family released
of course they would be like no no I
don't want his daughter no I mean he's a
bad guy he's just gotta think he's
probably closet Chris burrows or he's
now he's bi and just whatever get booty
for the suck dick and do get rocks in
his ass yeah but if that's what he likes
I don't care man he still is one of the
best on that news do you bring that
[ __ ] more than 9 news are feels great
on the show raters old 43 9 years
younger than me that's a bummer
some people have those crazy secrets and
it's fine what do we let them have a
then we learn from this don't put your
yes
don't put rocks in your ass well you
know the fastest way to absorb something
besides your mouth is your [ __ ] yeah
in your mouth brother is that true
bastard that's what I do a suppository
and all that stuff yeah yeah you're
right fast faster that's why a lot of
people like alcoholics would put vodka
in there nice and they die because goes
there's no filter it was strain to your
body on your bloodstream yeah huh
your patek seen your booty hole Matthew
I mean I know I mean Jesus yeah X in
your butt it's a yep what about a
terrible thing but but I mean just I you
know his wife and his daughter
go back to their privates no but don't
put rocks in your ass I understand but
you know it's he doesn't he doesn't mean
it deserves that I know they don't
deserve it either I hate this [ __ ] I
hate social media what a shitty shitty
way to we'll move bro sorry
you get all froggy go I'm fried Oh be
well be one those Hollywood go I'm going
to Canada
um yes all wrong I'm trouble - [ __ ] this
you guys wrong I'm going off grid I'm
going I'm going to Canada well let me
show you how tough it is that Canada
doesn't go yeah come on board it doesn't
work about that you [ __ ] ignorant Fox
yeah you can't do no what you need to do
is you know pay your harness to our boy
here take two rocks and put them up your
pooper I - yeah have a trip bro why did
you use two fingers what would you do go
like that root one Rock each finger well
sir would you push them in well I'd girl
I'd bring it up to the anus then you
just suck it in you'd go digits wise
so you'd actually put your digits in my
butt nope I get it closer said you would
and then Uranus picks them up like a
vein like a vacuum I'm gonna tell you if
I find out if I ever find out that you
art you passed away god forbid in a
motel
the first thing I'm gonna do is go who
was the guy really yeah see I'll do that
with you as soon as said Brian passes
out in or Brian dead Vancouver 59 years
old I'd go welp hate to tell you he has
rocks in his anus yeah check his
magazine eyes but you're you're curious
this is your this is vogue like you man
dude hey this is well-documented
remember that shady story told on the
last podcast how that young actor was
maybe Gainey took them out to dinner
and he came out to just you you don't
think everyone listing including chin
and cat assumed you sucked him off after
you found out he's gay when I was
helping him with this game you have
course that makes all the sense in the
world no do you don't think everyone was
oh do you know Matt nice to come to
dinner man I could tell what let's have
a talk weird dude it's my moustache
super funny story though what else you
guys I told you [ __ ] guys have to
jump to the worst possible conclusion oh
no no no there's no jump to conclusions
okay this is a bona fide case closed I
wanted to do to Asia I mean I was Brian
yeah sure yeah I'm but dude I hurt my
neck can you help me you have neck you
know neck issues when I turn this way it
catches mm I don't know what else you
got here this kid who is a projected
number one overall NBA draft pick
Mystikal Bron James yes right he's a
absolute freak during game his shoe
broke his Nike shoe isn't loaded yeah
and it injured his knee but he's only
out for a few weeks
Kobe's what's not too bad but he's like
he's look homie that bonafide number one
pick him or the kiss from daily
well-timed close damn button right at
high school but they had a rule you go
to college for one year so now the NBA's
switching that because of this they're
saying alright you can for
College because everyone's one-and-done
they're just like oh I'm out
he's a absolute [ __ ] free so is he
only one urine he's me out just a
man-child
Superman child how big is he but console
William plays basketball yeah if it kind
of got a football I don't know about
that I can't believe never heard of Zion
Williams 24 6 7 he's 1 4 6 7 oh my lord
have mercy and he's how old sir 18 come
on what what monster frame it's like
you're from a different country yes me
yes I thought you have Zion Williams is
he any good
where's he's you can go the NBA that
dude is 18 mm-hmm
lord have mercy he's a freak of all
freaks to that if you turn on ESPN he's
on every everything well now at 18 so
he's gonna fill out arguably and he'll
be he said he put on a hundred pounds
since he was 15 and grew like 9 inches
yeah sir he's gonna be probably another
[ __ ] on another 20 pounds
dude you should see him dunk it is
[ __ ] visually oh my god tonight when
you're jacking off to men videos look up
Zion Williams
I gotta bust that nut all right he's
dunking Oh complete freak man
yeah well he's gonna be your next New
York Knicks superstar he's gonna be on
the Knicks to be him and Durant there me
good Jesus maybe Kyrie Irving what else
you got Chris I was worth he's gonna be
doing a biopic for ass playing Hulk
Hogan
I'm all set on Hulk bro isn't he Thor
yeah Oh how's that work what what's
wrong with best shave tan up get on a
lot of Jews he's Thor get huge but he
he's [ __ ] Thor man can't bounce over
to Hulk
yeah you can't looks like Jack next to
me like 9 out the jokerman I'm gonna
play Batman dick all right
that's [ __ ] no one else has an issue
with this god that's him man he's door
and all sound I'm [ __ ] Oh director
Todd Phillips hold up scroll up
that's hot I'm sorry I'm off you're
thinking in the hole I'm thinking V Hall
and that's what I just heard I saw Hulk
I didn't see the hole I was like how are
they kill em just jumped the show I see
I'm another superhero
dude Hulk Oh we'd [ __ ] ride brother
that's awesome
I'm all on board on their hair Wow for a
second I was going crazy
well Josh Brolin's did it he was in
Deadpool and he's uh
Thanos that's right hey guys I wonder if
I'll get the call I wonder if I'll be in
the movie hopefully you are dude I
wonder if I'll have a small part hey
Todd look at that let's go produced by
Phillips and Bradley Cooper yeah yeah
portray Hulk Hogan in a film hell yeah
that's dope love it man all right Wow
how's the cows know and irate about
sir-sir
Hogan's only 53 no no he's younger than
you bro that doesn't make sense it does
make sense cuz his body has been through
oh-hoh an ism is is in his 60s there's
no he's 53 look it up there's no way
well I'll put as all the money you want
Hulk Hogan is much older than me
65 thank you I was like what so maybe
they're playing him at the 53 year old
age I don't know
Hogan 53 or there's just a bad he just
[ __ ] it yeah that's they just probably
messed up good call Brian yeah you know
you're Hogan uh-huh all right this is
getting updates constantly but some more
Jesse small it updates the the text I
just found out that he was texting with
those guys before and after and there's
a check involved right did you guys hear
about the check yeah 3500 check however
Charles Barkley they'd be kind of like
they read they covered their steps
because it said it was for like working
out and diet yeah for sure
all right well they do roll in the
mountain and put wrote something else
then I could put for staging attack no
no no but then they also texted each
other the text just came out right now
from TMZ
oh that's another one too Terrence
Howard had a meltdown regarding him
we'll just check this out first so
here's the check and then they'll show
the text damn it and that that police
sergeant was on Good Morning America
this morning have you heard it no I love
this I love this speech so this is some
of the text right here actually put down
like this is your gross list are you
good with everything on here all right
coconut oil Smuckers okay how many times
a day do you eat like twice if you can't
eat allergies not that I know of but I
did an allergy test with my throat
doctor he said I can suck dick we'll
have results in a week I don't eat pork
or beef though okay so you're all right
for now dairy oh sorry yeah no dairy
horrible for my vocal all right what is
this for though these artists text to
the the goons that he hired what is your
music video shoot here this is the meal
plan to break down micronutrient
southern clues all right cool I can't
pull up the phone okay this is boring
keep going
so this is you know they left to go to
Nigeria so this is the last messages so
he has some sort of stuff on his side
because of these texts because people
thought that they were texting about the
actual attack and then these are all
like different things your patient
there's nothing here kid no but you
understand it's just alright if they had
text if they show the text and it said
something else we are not stupid enough
to but hey thing wins things went great
sweet move when you put the history try
to fight this yeah he's definitely try
to fight this and then what what
happened with Terrence Howard
oh but also you know that police chief
he was a demeanor like no he paid these
guys forever 35 bucks for this it makes
him look bad to me when I get all the
facts do you think you think that police
chief is gonna say that not have all he
said straight out he paid he paid him
thirty five hundred dollars for that you
know I'm saying like so he's if you
would have said like oh it says this but
we assume it's for the you know the
attack it would have been different
so he's screwing himself by saying that
the please the chief yeah I don't know
messes up that case a little bit sources
tell Empire State so he went straight
from jail
to the set you did and then they fired
him from the show they thought they
thought he was gonna be like oh I'm so
sorry or they happened he was like I'm
sorry for everything I put you guys
through I didn't do it though I didn't
do it he still claims his innocence so
they're like half of the room and half
of the room or like somewhere like with
him and somewhere against them that says
source I didn't probably tells TMZ
Thursday was a complete disaster on set
after Jesse turned himself into Chicago
police Terrence was so upset refused
coming out of his trailer for most of
the day sources close to Terrence tell
us that after didn't believe Jesse's
account from the get-go he felt the
story never added up we're told Terrence
grilled Jesse Priyanka tension between
Terrence and Jesse boiled over after two
Nigerian American brothers blah blah
blah tame by please we're told Terrence
confronted Jessie once again screaming
at him to come clean Jesus yeah so this
guy Terrence Howard I think you know
foolish tweeted or put an Instagram post
recently in support of them but then
this shows otherwise you can't do it
tonight because it's your life your life
is over
yeah it's games we all know we all know
you're full of [ __ ] like the Chicago
Police Department they've done crime
before they can follow the video it's
called evidence and they also don't play
in the game of drama like the Chicago
Police isn't gonna come out and say wow
you paid 3500 like well they have this
check for 30 bucks they're singing like
Canaries tier so it's like alright enjoy
that are killing Jesse they're in the
same jail are Kelly's in the same jail
yeah both their mug shots are in the
same background that's why I never both
folks in Chicago yeah cuz they're from
Chicago Kelly's [ __ ] yeah yeah preying
on little girls and then you're screwed
oh you're proposing they don't play yes
and also and just II kind of like taking
advantage of being blackened and a noose
and all that stuff like you know
oh he's you me begin that superintendent
is black in Chicago says black man I can
tell you that this is a you know it
makes it doubly is worse
[ __ ] [ __ ] you saw him speak to
write the chief yes he was super pissed
off like you more America I don't know I
came from that easy the tear tomorrow
he's on it and he's supposed to like
tell all like they see what they said
there's way more evidence coming out so
he says there's $3500 check he trust me
he's gonna nobody doubts that this
[ __ ] guy did it you know he's a liar
oh yeah everyone already believes that
there's no hood don't think you know
anyone who's still at I don't know bro
do you know anyone it was like
Charlemagne's donkey of the day too you
know he does donkey of it yeah for
terrible people
yeah he called our dysphoria of course
yeah especially a terrible move for gay
people there really matter alright what
else we got I think that's it for
currents those are good man those were
good it's a good god casting thank you
some blocks of my hack you guys hey guys
let's do our dates bring them up yeah
I'm in Miami March I'm back on the road
March is a busy time for me yes I'm in
Miami March 15 through the 16th Miami
improv and then just added Milwaukee
theater Pabst Theater Milwaukee I've
never been there that is March 22nd
through the 23rd one show Friday one
should one show Saturday that's coming
up fast we just announced let's get
moving Milwaukee we got some tickets to
move in Washington DC DC improv March
28th to the 30th get tickets now for
Brian on myself tea fat K calm also new
sweatshirts new shirts and hats are
available on T fat K calm as well cutie
pies Salt Lake City I think we're almost
sold out already
March 1st and March 2nd two shows each
night and then Kansas City improv I'll
be there March 22nd 23rd Friday Saturday
Kansas City improv get your tickets and
Philadelphia March 28th 29th and 30th
come see me t fat K dr. Liam comedy club
this the funk kid were out where our
[ __ ]